it's not often we get a new photograph
of the Queen and the Duke of Edinburgh
but with Prince Phillip turning 99 it is
a big birthday worthy of something
special taken last week in the grounds
at Windsor Castle with possibly a hidden
tribute in what the Duke is wearing
Prince Philip is wearing his favorite
coat which is the boating jacket of the
Grenadier Guards and it was given to him
by a great friend set Eric Penn in his
will so Eric had been to all the
different auction houses and had bought
the different buttons from different
sovereigns each has a different badge
going back to William the fourth after
stepping back from royal duties in 2017
Prince Philip is rarely seen in public
since lockdown started he's been at
Windsor with the Queen from where
they've both sent out messages of
support to key workers and be taking
some exercise whatever problems she's
had she's been able to take them to him
and he has been there supportive and
loyal and I think that they represent
the sort of continuity really and
continuity when people really need
continuity last week
Prince Charles told us how much he was
missing Prince Philip well I mean I
haven't seen my father he's he's going
to be 99 next week and so yes well my
grandchildren willing so I've been doing
but the face time is over over social
distancing will of course get in the way
of any family celebrations not that that
should really matter for a couple who've
spent more than seven decades by each
other site lien on Mills Sky News